[Music]
I've been a maintainer of MOCA since
mid-2014 I work at IBM as a developer
advocate in the IOT and emerging
technology area
I'm bone skull on on github
and Twitter except with a zero on
Twitter and so I'm gonna talk today this
is kind of just a introduction to unit
testing nodejs apps with mocha this is
this is really kind of low-level it's I
kind of wrote it with you know having
someone who's never really done this
before in mind and so yeah I'm just
gonna kind of run through some
fundamentals of testing just just a
couple concepts just just keep it really
short because there's a lot of concepts
but just just I'm just gonna do a couple
then we'll talk about how to write a
unit test with mocha and I'll show you
that process and then we'll move on to
an integration test with mocha as well
and if there's questions about anything
along the way just pipe up and stop me
so what is mocha mocha is a testing
framework so a testing framework as a
few responsibilities when those
responsibilities is providing an API to
help you write tests automated tests
against your software a test framework
also help you organize this test some
test frameworks more than others will
actually let you run the tests too and
you look is one of those and also
another responsibility is they report
the results of the tests so you you
write them and you run them and at the
end you get you know in various human or
machine readable formats
this is what happened with the test this
is these are the ones that failed and
this is why etc etc so mocha mocha runs
in nodejs
of course and that's what I'm going to
talk about I'm not going to talk about
testing in the browser with mocha
because milk also runs in the browser
it runs in right now the oldest browser
we support is IE 9 but I think we're
gonna ditch that soon I then the oldest
one will be ie 11 hopefully you don't
need to actually we never tested Opera I
have no idea I just pulled that off
anyway so so what's cool about mocha
mocha is simple it's got this it's got a
very small API surface it's it's easy to
learn there's there's really just not a
lot you have to remember when working
with it kind of does one job and it
seems to do it well it lets you write
your tests and it kind of wants to get
out of the way and because of that it's
actually it's very versatile so it will
kind of bend how you want to you know
how do you how you want to push it you
know it's it's not limited to simply one
kind of test you can write many
different kinds of tests you can run
that test in many different environments
you know you can use reporters designed
for nodejs running in a headless browser
and still output you know like weird
stuff to the console and just you just
they're things I never consider that
people use this for and of course you
know they file bugs about all this weird
stuff so one of the things okay is that
the entire user facing API the thing
that you in you interact with as a
developer writing your test the whole
thing can be swapped out there's a
default which is this kind of r-spec
style
API but but it can also milk also ships
with if you're more comfortable with
with the way to unit works which is I
think originally q unit was written to
test jQuery itself if you're if you're
familiar with that you can write your
mocha tests in in Q unit format or
there's several different ways you can
do it and if you don't like any of them
you can even write your own and just use
it and I haven't seen too many of that
too many of those the defaults work
pretty well for a lot of people mocha is
also I daresay fun for a testing
framework I suppose because there's
really no other testing framework that
has an in cat reporter that I know of
anyway so now I'm going to talk a little
bit about some fundamentals so this is
kind of this is what milk is and now
we're gonna go into fundamentals of
testing and so this is just gonna be
like three
this is terminology and this is not
we're not going to go very deep it won't
hurt I promise the first thing is the
assertion and so what is an assertion
it's it's a fundamentally it's a
comparison and if the comparison is is
true or truth II nothing happens if the
comparison is false or false II then it
throws an exception and it's really
trivial to write your own assertion in
function and here's here's an example so
you pass assert an a value if that value
evaluates to false II throw an error
that's that's basically what an
assertion is testing you know testing
you're gonna make a lot of assertions
and your tests that's that's kind of
that's kind of the idea so the next term
is the unit test and so a unit test it's
kind of like this recursive acronym or
not
it's the definition is is it's well it's
a test of a unit and and that doesn't
mean anything right you have to know the
unit is and so a unit test asserts a
unit behaves as intended so a unit is
the smallest testable chunk of code so
you know generally that's going to be a
function because you can't very easily
crawl inside a function and pull a
little bit out and just test that piece
so we're talking about functions most of
the time but not always you know you can
have a unit test that maybe is testing
events or something like that where it's
it's not a function itself that you're
testing per se so hey you nut test then
has two responsibilities one it executes
the unit and so I may refer to this as
the unit under test or code under test
the unit test then makes an assertion
about whatever it just did and so in the
case of a function that returns
something like say you have a function
and it adds two numbers that is your
unit let's call it call it add or
something and you pass it you know two
and two
your unit tests is going to execute that
function and then it's going to make an
assertion that the function returned or
so that's that's one way if your unit
just does some side effects and we'll
see that here in a minute like you know
maybe it modifies some application state
you can just you know your unit test is
going to execute your function and then
it's going to make an assertion about
the state of the application so here's
here's the last concept there's only
three I'm gonna do so it's the
integration test and so I found when I
started writing unit tests
would not really be sure what I was
doing or in some cases the code I was
trying to test was just very poor and
and coupled too tightly and I was trying
to write unit tests in fact that's what
I thought I was doing but I was writing
integration tests and so an integration
test asserts like a a it's it's a test
across multiple units or multiple
modules multiple layers of your
application or multiple subsystems when
your unit test starts testing other
units to you you just wrote an
integration test and you can get really
confused and your whole tests all your
tests can get really confused and but if
you find yourself doing that all the
time it might be a sign that that it's
not the test that that's the problem
it's it's that your codes not very
testable so an integration test is is a
test across you know groups or layers
and if that sounds vague it's because it
is vague and it depends on your your
software's you know the kind of
application you have maybe a web server
you'll have an integration test you know
between you know something that's gonna
hit hit hit a adjacent endpoint or
something maybe a command line app it's
gonna have something different a desktop
app whatever you know an integration
test is really just depends on what
you're trying to test you may not know
how I feel like this is this is like
required to put in a tutorial like this
this is how you install mocha with NPM
how you install most things I recommend
you use it as a development dependency
with I like capital D some people like
SAV dev but whatever so this is how you
install mocha in node if you're gonna
use it in the browser it's a different
story maybe so
nevermind that I'm just talking about no
this is how you do a note and so what
happens when you do this well mocha is
added to your manifest which is
package.json it's in the dev
dependencies property it becomes part of
that in that object and it also gives
you the mocha executable which lives in
your local node modules in the dot bi in
folder I have no idea what that looks
like on Windows all of this is going to
be you know linux e eunuch c type stuff
I'm not sure exactly how that works on
Windows but so you get a mocha executive
well it's an it's in your your manifest
and next time you're on NPM install
you'll get mocha so great but if we're
installing mocha that means we have
something to test and so this is what we
have to test so this is the obligatory
contrived example which is some Express
middleware I couldn't think of I mean I
don't know what else to do it's
something that it's kind of practical
but really really simple so if you're
familiar with Express Express is like
the the the defaults I think like web
free more web server framework for
nodejs it's what you're probably gonna
reach for there are other ones but most
people just use Express it seems
and so expresses is kind of this wrapper
around you know nodes built in HTTP
server and it it basically functions as
this as like a list of its it's built
out of these things called middleware
and so middleware is just a function
this is this is this is middleware it's
it's function accepts three parameters
when you build an express act
you basically chain all these things
together used to
routes and you know what happens when a
a request comes into your server is that
request gets filtered Durance sent
through all this different middleware
and and eventually something happens and
you get your response and so a
middleware function accepts a request
which is req which is this object that
represents the the request whether
that's a get request a post requests and
somebody's some machine hitting your web
server and the response object which is
going to be this thing you're building
and that's what you're eventually going
to return and send it back to the
requester and then there's this this
third parameter to middleware which is
this which is next and it's a function
and it says I'm done doing what I'm
doing go ahead and execute the next
middle way or whatever that is you don't
really care what it is it's just like
it's it's like a queue and you know
knocks off the next one and so this
particular bit of middleware it adds a
request time property to the request
object and so it's it's not a it's a
JavaScript timestamp which is not a UNIX
timestamp because it's in milliseconds
anyway that's what it does and that's
all it does and so we decided we wanted
to write a unit test for this and so
we're gonna make one mocha will it has
some defaults which I think are pretty
reasonable if you make a folder called
test mocha assumes that if you give it
no other information it assumes your
test files are in there and so if you
make a test directory and and put a file
in it with a dot J s extension it will
find that file and execute it by
convention we like to name these files
with the dot spec J s I don't know where
that came from but
it's one of those things well we always
did it that way so that's kind of how
we're doing it but it's it's a good way
to say you know just visually tell oh
this is a test and not not a source file
some people like to put them next to the
source files which is another way to do
it so but anyway by default
it looks in this test directory and the
file we're gonna create these requests -
time dot spec Jas which will contain
unit tests for this middleware and
before I go any further and this is this
is something that that people get really
religious about it's that mokey uses
Global's when you go and you want to
write a test that you know milk is going
to run you don't have a like require
mocha like give me all these functions
at the top of your test file you don't
have import stuff from mocha mocha
doesn't even use a namespace it doesn't
even have like that like sort of you
know courtesy it simply just dumps
everything into the global namespace and
you know in the browser that's going to
be the window object and not-it's the
global object and so why the only reason
I can think of now I didn't write mocha
I just maintain it but you know I can
only speculate why some of the decisions
were made but it reduces boilerplate
plain and simple it's a trade-off design
decision that was made this is you know
I don't want to have to require all this
crap at the top of every file because I
got 400 test files if we simply throw
things into the global message but we
did it anyway and so there it is it's
for developer ergonomics more or less it
reduces boilerplate and some people
don't like this but it is what it is
what we want to do is create a suite and
so what's a suite it's it's a way to
organize your tests so a suite
contain tests contain something called
hooks that I'm not going to talk about
but you can also put other sweets in
them we use a function called describe
to create a sweet and you give it a
title and a callback function and the
callback is the body of the sweet and so
the title is you know basically this is
this logical organization whatever makes
sense to you you can nest the hell out
of these things or not it's up to you
but since we're gonna write a test for
the request time middleware that's what
we're calling the suite ostensibly we
would have more than one but in this
talk we do not and so next we're gonna
start trying to turn the write a unit
test but another kind of gotcha about
mocha is that it doesn't actually
contain anything - oops but so the
question was can about conventions for
naming Suites naming tests and and so
you know I feel like some people who
really are into this the whole BDD thing
which I'm not gonna go into you can look
it up it's behavior driven development
it's it's more than just like it's more
than just coding you know it's it's like
a whole like business process thing and
if you're really into that I'm sure they
have some really nice rules that you get
to adhere to but I'm not one of those
people and I don't think most people do
that and so I think at some level it
doesn't matter too much what I like to
do personally is I will have like a
suite and it will kind of give a basic
description of where we're at if I have
some sort of condition I might want and
and within that condition I need to have
multiple tests they like to have one
assertion protest and so if I have
a suite with you know with with some
condition and then I'll have some tests
in there and then I would like try to
try to chain them with and and say so
you know we'd start with describe
request time middle layer describe when
such and such is true and then we're
gonna have another describe and such and
such as false
it should blah blah blah and so I try to
make it kind of like a sentence but I
don't go crazy about it I mean there
there's there's things I mean if you
have a tests test this you know like
typescript I think is the biggest
consumer of mocha that I know of
they have like thousands and thousands
of tests maybe should ask them how they
do it because like I can't imagine how
to organize something like that but you
know I think just just whatever works
for you is fine there's there's really
there's no reason in my mind to you know
some people like to have like special
tokens in there so they can grep for
things and stuff and I don't know but so
and you'll see that there's I talked a
little bit about this kind of English
language type type thing but so mocha
mocha doesn't have any functionality in
it to make assertions which is odd for a
test framework it seems like kind of a
fundamental part of the test framework
right so with other test frameworks like
maybe Jasmine you get the whole
enchilada and like Jasmine is really
similar to mocha you you just you get
everything with Jasmine you get your
spies your stubs your assertion
framework blah blah blah you get
everything in there but mocha doesn't
and again I don't know why one can
speculate maybe maybe the original
author felt that it was simply you know
the
the best way to to give people the
flexibility to work the way they want
maybe he was lazy you didn't want to do
it I don't know but I could I can look
at this problem now with with hindsight
and say you know he made the right
choice because you know after he he
wrote mocha and it started to take off
it started this kind of a market or this
like you know all these little assertion
libraries started popping up and and now
there's quite a few and they're all
different and so people have found lots
of different ways that they want to
write assertions and certainly now local
couldn't support all these you know it's
it's kind of there's like unexpected and
in chai try especially is an assertion
library that has its own ecosystem
I mean it's there's there's just like a
ton that you can do and I think I think
originally the the the right choice was
made not to kind of go there with the
assertion library but note comes with
one there's an assert module node uses
this assert module to test itself and
we're also going to need our middleware
and so this is our unit test file and
we're just going to pull the assert
module we're gonna pull in our
middleware and next we're going to
create a test and so before we had
described for a suite and then in the
suite body we put a test and you create
cysts with it title callback very
similar you can see here kind of went
out a little bit but so putting this
more together so we have a request time
middleware it should add a request time
property to the req parameter which is
basically all that little minimal
nowhere function is doing and so here we
have a call function make assertion most
notes this is what's going to go in
there and it's if you kind of write your
tests like a sentence then the reporting
will look a little nicer
so here we go here is here is my first
try at at the unit test and so my unit
test is going to call a request time
it's going to pass a empty object and
why is it going to pass an empty object
well you know this middleware function
you have to when you're writing unit
tests you have to think of that unit as
a completely standalone piece of code it
doesn't it shouldn't be coupled anything
else really and you know the middleware
as you wrote it it doesn't know anything
about express all it knows is it gets
three parameters and and you know it
adds a property to some object and so
the the object that it adds property to
might as well just be an empty object
and this is an example of a unit that
just basically has side effects it
doesn't return anything so we got we
have this you know we call a request
time and so now the state should be
modified and we can make an assert and
so making a surgeon so assert okay okay
is is maybe it's the same thing as the
assert function I don't know but
basically you pass something to okay and
if that something is true C then it
passes if not it's false it's very very
simple just pretty much the same kind of
bare-bones assertion function or before
and so if you know what's gonna happen
in here don't spoil the surprise it's
good surprise I promise now we're gonna
run this and so how do we run it we it's
ends up in node modules and so we just
call mocha it looks in a test folder it
runs all the files in that test folder
in it fails because why so what do we
see here we see this first line request
time is aware this is the sweet below
that is a test and
I believe that yeah that number shows up
to cross-reference down here it's a
number if it fails it's a check if it
passes and we can see we have no passing
tests and seven millisecond so one
failing test in seven milliseconds and
what happened so it gives us the suite
again that failed it gives us the test
title that failed and writer that it
gives us a stack trace and then stack
trace goes on a while I cut it off there
but the important part is next is not a
function and so why is next not a
function it's because our middleware
tries to call a function called next and
we didn't give it one
oops so let's take a look at quest time
source again okay so what can we get we
could we could do it like this so we
have that empty object again and the
second parameter it needs a second
parameter we don't use the second
parameter for anything but it needs
something in there right so no it could
be void zero it could be anything it
could be foo if you want it doesn't use
it doesn't matter and but the the third
parameter is a function it simply calls
a function and so it has to be a
function that function doesn't have to
do anything and so then we assert that
the request time property is greater
than zero and run it again and great it
pasts so does anybody have any questions
about this kind of this this flow of
reading unit tests and executing milk on
yes it's stubbing it's just I would call
this stuff yeah and so you're gonna find
yourself creating something called stubs
when you're writing into tests quite
often where you have some dummy data or
maybe that that unit calls another
function somewhere and maybe you need to
stub that out because you don't really
care what that does or or you want to
say oh so I have function a that calls
function B well what happens when
function B what happens to function a
when function b return such-and-such you
have this stub or this this that
basically pretends it's function B and
returns a certain value and that's kind
of up to you and so there's there's a
lot of kind of bickering about what's
best there and I think I think it more
comes down to not how your tests are
written more importantly how your how
your actual code is written but your
tests can be indicative that your code
is not good and so this passed that's
great we have an integration test
example and so again an integration test
is it's like it's the next level up from
a unit test it's it's like you pull back
and you get this higher level view it's
it's as far as we're gonna go with this
one but so what do we have
you're looking at an expressed based web
server here and so all this thing is
doing is it's it it creates an express
server it pulls in our middleware
and then it registers a root that's this
app duck get and so when I start this
server on port 3000 and if I go to the
path if I go to you know localhost colon
3,000 for size UNIX - timestamp it's
gonna execute this code and so what this
read is about Jason thing does is that
it its sticks a J sort of response in
there in a JSON object and the response
built from my object here
and remember if I mentioned that a
JavaScript time stamp is not a unix time
steam but one of UNIX timestamp and so
we need to turn that in the second
that's but as good as we're gonna get
there
and finally this bit at the bottom I
don't know some of you may have seen
something like this before but basically
what you can do with this file is you
can either require it or you can execute
it straight away so you can say node app
J s and then it'll start listening on
port 3000 but if you require it from
some other module it will not listen
because that's not the main module it's
just kind of an easy way and maybe not
the best way but it's a way to to get at
this application that we've created and
tested from you know integration testing
standpoint and one thing with
integration testing and as you get kind
of to a higher and higher level when
you're testing your code we should go to
integration test or finally you end up
with end-to-end tests where you're you
know you're hitting a browser maybe and
and and clicking some buttons and and it
tests all the way through the data layer
you know the higher up you get the more
tooling you need and so here we are in
integration tests and this would really
be a pain in the ass to test without
some nice helpers and so there's a great
helper called super test and super test
is a it's basically it's like a mutant
assertion framework that helps you test
Express servers and you're gonna be
expressed to but super tests so
basically it it runs these requests
against and a server object you don't
have to start a server in process a and
then tab over and then start your tests
and start hitting hitting the the
endpoint you just give it the server
object and you can work with it directly
which is kind of nice you know you don't
have to listen on
port apparently it's a lot quicker you
know I haven't used it too much but here
it is super test and so we have our
assert as before we have our app and so
this was that thing I just showed you
which is this this dude this is a pas
and so we pull that in and we have our
sweet get UNIX timestamp so all the
stuff that we want to test when that
endpoint is hit with a get request we
might have multiple tests in here but we
just have one and our tests and should
respond with JSON object containing
timestamp and so this the same type of
thing that we're asserting before but
we're asserting it at a higher level now
we want to make sure that you know not
only was request time you know written
properly not only does that function do
what we thought it should do but our
whole system works you know the point of
our system is to have an endpoint with
the returning unix timestamp and without
this integration test how can we be sure
other than you know test manually
because our unit tests won't tell us if
our actually works and this won't really
tell us that but it'll get us closer so
there's a couple ways to do it one is
this node back style with callbacks and
this is an example of a asynchronous
mocha test and so when you're using
super test you're making HTTP requests
in tests these are asynchronous in this
case so it's kind of magic in mocha you
give it this done function and if that
done function exists
Moke will expect you to call it it
doesn't care when it will eventually
timeout after so long
but it wants you to call done at some
point and so you can do all sorts of
async stuff in here and then when you're
finished you call done
and super test is a request function and
we pass it our app instance that we had
before dot get would be you know pretend
um I get requests to the UNIX timestamp
path of this server we expect this is
kind of the assertion portion we expect
two hundred ok status back and then
finally when we're done if there's an
error which I don't think there really
could be an error here but if there is
we can hand that back to done and so
this is the kind of error first callback
thing that was so popular it still is
for some people but finally if that's ok
we can make our assertion again and so
what I did there was you know now that I
have you know divided this millisecond
style timestamp by a thousand I can now
be sure that it's a UNIX tile timestamp
maybe if it's under this very large
number if I didn't do that
you know division this would fail anyway
so that's one way to do it but that way
sucks so this way is even better and you
can probably get even better to with a
sneaky weight but with mocha you can
simply return a promise and if you
return a promise from and test it says
oh you're an async test ok great
and so this just works with promises the
same exact test is before so we we check
to make sure we got a 200 ok and then we
look at the response and in that body
which has been like magically becomes a
JavaScript object out of its JSON format
we checked the timestamp and so there we
go and so we just run Milkha it finds
that we just added this other I can't
remember what I called this file but we
tossed it in there and into the tester
and it just ran both oh so the question
was do if you have an asynchronous test
is it reported asynchronously or is it
as a reported in in order
the answer is reported in order momoka
is it only works in serial it will not
execute two tests at a time if it's
doing something like that you're
probably gonna get a really hard to
debug error and you're doing something
wrong but yeah it just runs it's gonna
run UNIX timestamp and it's gonna hang
it out there and wait until that's done
before it goes to this other file it's
yeah it runs everything in order in it
it will not try to you know do two
things at once yeah that's that's that's
about all I got so you know before this
Ben said I was super positive which is
really weird and so but I don't want to
let him down there you go that's all
folks balloons and emoji and a poop and
this this the slides and the example
code is up there at this URL and you can
download it and install it and run it
and stuff there's all sorts of all that
code is an example folder
[Applause]
[Music]
you